i
[Música]
los bombardeos en la región separatista
de donges que no cesan el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr se les guía afirma
que moscú quiere deshabilitar la región
y el ejército de kiev sostiene que es
una estrategia para evitar el
reagrupamiento de sus fuerzas
los presidentes de estados unidos y de
méxico hablaron telefónicamente de este
viernes joe biden y andrés manuel lópez
obrador discutieron la migración a la
casa blanca señaló que fue un diálogo
constructivo
falta exactamente un mes para la primera
vuelta presidencial en colombia el
izquierdista gustavo petro es el
favorito pero el candidato de derecha
federico gutiérrez cada vez le recorta
más distancia en los sondeos
para noches y bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 mi nombre es maría clara
calle y es un placer volver a estar con
ustedes y empezamos en ucrania el
ejército del país sostiene que rusia
está bombardeando a la región de donges
que para evitar el reagrupamiento de las
fuerzas ucranianas mientras que el
presidente de volodymyr se le skin acusa
a moscú de querer deshabilitar la zona
una muestra de los ataques rusos en el
donbass es que el viernes derribaron un
puente ferroviario entre las ciudades de
slomianski y liman esta última es
considerada como un importante nudo
ferroviario en el este ucraniano que
permite suministrar armas a las tropas
por otro lado moscú concentra sus
esfuerzos en mantener su posición en
kharkiv la segunda ciudad más importante
previamente hablamos con leticia álvarez
enviado especial de france 24 y quien
nos amplió la información desde la
ciudad de micro
el ejército ruso está avanzando muy
lentamente en el este de ucrania en la
batalla del donbass esa batalla de
desgaste que se centra en don slogans y
jarkiv aunque en las últimas horas
tropas ucranianas han derribado un avión
de combate en jarkiv y han bombardeado
una estación de tren y un tren de
mercancías en donges donges es una
ciudad que lleva bajo mandato pro ruso
desde el año 2014 de hecho nosotros en
la zona donde nos encontramos que hace
frontera con el donbass hemos estado
escuchando durante todo el día las
fuerzas aéreas ucranianas y el sonido de
las sirenas antiaéreas hoy por primera
vez un asesor de excellence que ha
reconocido que este país está sufriendo
serias pérdidas y entre esas pérdidas
los civiles hoy ha habido más víctimas
mortales en la zona donde se centra en
los combates en kharkiv y en donges
además hoy también se les ha informado
de que han encontrado una nueva fosa
común en la región de kiev con 900
cuerpos que tienen que ser identificados
la organización mundial de la salud
reportó que más de 170 170 centros
hospitalarios han sido atacados en
ucrania desde que inició la guerra estos
ataques han dejado 73 muertos nuestras
enviadas especiales a territorio
ucraniano irene sabio y leticia álvarez
lograron entrar a uno de los hospitales
más importantes de cni pro esta es la
historia
la guerra no se apaga en el este de
ucrania clínicas infantiles atacadas y
miles de heridos en todo el país
atenderlos se ha convertido en una
misión difícil para los médicos como
esta doctora que gestiona un hospital en
libro prefiere no mostrar su rostro para
no poner en peligro el centro de salud
no ocurra ni una gran cantidad de
hospitales fueron destruidos en todo el
país a pesar de que tenían la bandera
blanca y que se entendía que eran
hospitales centros para niños
maternidades todos fueron destruidos
desde el cielo automotor pese a los
constantes ataques a los hospitales
andriy quien llegó con una herida grave
en el brazo reconoce que ha sido bien
atendido
me habían puesto un torniquete y como
los combates continuaron no pudieron
evacuar me rápido y estuve mucho tiempo
en la mano con él
por estos
170 centros sanitarios han sido atacados
desde el inicio de este conflicto según
la organización mundial de la salud
ataques en los que han fallecido unas 70
personas
un combatiente de ser casi herido por un
ataque con misiles en dones está con
vida gracias a la atención recibida en
este hospital de guerra
agradezco desde lo más profundo de mi
corazón a los médicos que me salvaron la
pierna me devolvieron esperanza y que la
paz pueda finalmente llegar a ucrania
los médicos que trabajan en ucrania se
encuentran librando su propia lucha y
coma fuerza porque son unos de los
principales blancos de ataque en esta
guerra
tres provincias costeras de ecuador
entran en estado de excepción la medida
la tomó el presidente guillermo lasso
para combatir la delincuencia organizada
más de nueve mil policías y militares se
desplegarán en guayas manabí y
esmeraldas mientras que en las
parroquias de esmeraldas eloy alfaro y
jiménez pascuales habrá un toque de
queda desde las 11 de la noche hasta las
5 de la mañana el estado decepción
regirá a partir del sábado y se enmarca
en la creciente violencia que se vio en
la costa de ecuador por parte de las
bandas de narcotráfico del guayas manabí
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador y su homólogo
estadounidense joe biden hablaron
telefónicamente este viernes se
concentraron en la migración y es que la
casa blanca desea terminar con el
llamado título 42 una orden que permite
la expulsión de migrantes para evitar la
propagación de kobe 19 mientras que a
méxico le preocupa que esto aumente el
paso fronterizo vamos a ciudad de méxico
donde está el unirse rendón coordinadora
de agenda migrante y red viral señora
rendón bienvenida empecemos por explicar
que es el título 42 y cuáles son las
posturas de eeuu y méxico al respecto
el título 42 es una medida que tomó eeuu
para deportar con el pretexto de la
pandemia a más de un millón y medio de
migrantes en los últimos meses entonces
este título 42 y realmente no es una
medida de migración sino una medida de
salud pública que está justamente
avalada por los centros de control de
enfermedades de eeuu mejor conocidos
como cds es y bueno por eso es que ahora
el presidente bailén anunció
recientemente que debe terminar este
título 42 el próximo 23 de mayo sin
embargo recordemos que ya más de 21
estados republicanos se han interpuesto
y han interpuesto demandas para que esto
no suceda de hecho ya hay un juez
federal que está frenando el término de
este programa y la plática que tuvieron
el presidente mexicano y el presidente
estadounidense justamente habló sobre
título 42 y me imagino que también sobre
el programa permanece en mexico que hace
que los solicitantes de refugio en eeuu
tengan que esperar desde helado y que ha
cambiado el lado que ha cambiado en la
diplomacia entre eeuu y méxico desde la
llegada de joe biden al poder y le
preguntó específicamente por los temas
migratorios
lo primero que ha cambiado es el
lenguaje hay un lenguaje más amigable
por parte del presente vaivén
sin embargo en términos migratorios
seguimos teniendo muchas deportaciones
de hecho más que en la época de trump
bailén ha cuatriplicado las cifras de
deportados a nuestro país
haciéndonos llegar no solamente a
mexicanos sino también a miles de
centroamericanos que los deposita en
seis puntos fronterizos de méxico
también la próxima semana el presidente
de lópez obrador va a viajar a
centroamérica a guatemala salvador
honduras belice y la cuba también tras
este viaje a centroamérica y justo bueno
parece que esta llamada también tiene el
sentido de platicar con estos países el
hecho de que para frenar la migración es
decir evitar que salgan las personas se
habla de ir a las causas que es parte de
lo que se ha trabajado en la relación
bilateral sin embargo esto es una agenda
de largo plazo y la realidad es que la
gente
sigue emigrando los flujos ahí están y
han aumentado también en 2022 reunirse
reino gracias por estar con nosotros en
france 24
muchas gracias bueno hablamos ahora de
colombia porque exactamente en un mes
será la primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales el 29 de mayo de este año
se conocerá si hay un nuevo presidente
entre los 8 candidatos o si el
mandatario o mandataria se decidirá en
una segunda vuelta el 19 de junio por
ahora el aspirante favorito en las
encuestas es el izquierdista gustavo
petro seguido cada vez más de cerca por
el candidato de derecha federico
gutiérrez y detrás están rodolfo
hernández y sergio fajardo entre otros
los detalles los tiene luis muñoz
un presidente de izquierdas por primera
vez en colombia es la estimación de la
última encuesta de invamer que incluso
señala que en una hipotética segunda
vuelta gustavo petro también lideraría
la intención de voto a un mes de la
primera vuelta de la elección
presidencial el líder de izquierda
recorre plazas de todo el territorio
colombiano aboga en sus discursos por
reformas estructurales
[Música]
pues que se agrega valor a través de un
proceso industrial
la pregunta que tendríamos que hacernos
es por qué colombia el que produce el
maíz
sin embargo la diferencia se estrecha
cada vez más con federico gutiérrez el
candidato de la derecha ha subido 18
puntos en las encuestas por lo que para
muchos estamos ante un escenario similar
a 2018 cuando iván duque protagonizó una
remontada en los sondeos y terminó
superando a gustavo petro en la elección
no más división no más discursos de odio
y de lucha de clases si a la unidad de
colombia y si nos ponemos de acuerdo en
lo fundamental el centro representado
por sergio fajardo es el que más se
hunde ha perdido 18 5% de la intención
de voto por lo que en twitter hizo un
guiño a un posible pacto con el tercero
en las encuestas
el polémico candidato rodolfo hernández
son las estimaciones en una carrera
electoral que llevan meses al rojo vivo
después de que en las elecciones
legislativas del 13 de marzo los
candidatos de izquierda derecha y centro
fuesen escogidos en una consulta por
delante semanas vibrantes hasta el 29 de
mayo cuando se revelara si las encuestas
están en lo cierto
hubo un nuevo derrame de petróleo en
perú el organismo de evaluación y
fiscalización ambiental del ministerio
del ambiente de ese país detalló que el
crudo derramado desde la empresa sabia
el hecho ocurrió el pasado jueves 7
kilómetros mar adentro de la costa del
distrito de lobitos en el departamento
de piura las autoridades están evaluando
como respondió la compañía ante el
accidente éste vertimiento ocurre luego
de otros dos derrames de petróleo que
hubo en enero de este año
y un nuevo atentado en afganistán deja
decenas de muertos el ataque fue contra
la mezquita sunita califa así el líder
del templo afirma que 50 fieles
fallecieron mientras que ministerio del
interior afgano habla de 10 decesos el
atentado se produjo durante los rezos
del último viernes del mes sagrado del
ramadán y hace parte de una serie de
explosiones que ha habido desde que los
talibanes tomaron el poder
la tradicional oración del viernes
convertida en una masacre una brutal
explosión golpeó la abarrotada mezquita
califa sharif en el oeste de kabul la
capital afgana dejando decenas de
muertos y heridos incluyendo menores de
edad
entre 300 y 400 personas estaban
celebrando rituales cuando estalló la
explosión ayudé a llevar a los vehículos
a entre 10 y 15 heridos y a tres que
murieron muchos de los heridos y
martirizados siguen siendo evacuados de
la zona hay muchas víctimas
varios miembros de los talibanes también
estaban dentro de la mezquita y mientras
estábamos adorando y de pie para
terminar nuestro circo a los pocos
minutos se produjo una explosión yo
estaba cubierto de pequeños trozos de
los cuerpos de las víctimas
el nuevo atentado se produjo cuando los
fieles sunitas se reunían en el interior
del templo en una congregación conocida
como sir que es parte de las
celebraciones del mes sagrado musulmán
del ramadán el ataque se suma a la serie
de explosiones que se están viviendo en
todo afganistán
desde la llegada de los talibanes al
poder los últimos 10 días cerca de una
docena de explosiones han dejado más de
40 fallecidos naciones unidas y otros
organismos humanitarios condenaron los
hechos el ataque de hoy llevado a cabo
el último viernes del mes sagrado del
ramadán y en vísperas del eid al-fitr
ignora totalmente las vidas humanas y la
santidad religiosa ninguna palabra es
suficiente para condenar este acto
despreciable muchos de los ataques han
estado dirigidos contra la minoría
chiíta pero también contra mezquitas
sunitas la mayoría de estos actos han
sido reivindicados por la rama regional
del estado islámico que está en guerra
abierta contra los gobernantes talibanes
que insisten en que sus combatientes han
derrotado el estado islámico en el país
miras que los analistas reiteran que en
realidad supone un desafío para la
seguridad de afganistán
la organización reporteros sin fronteras
anunció que ayudará a france 24 la radio
francia internacional a seguir siendo
accesibles en mali a través de internet
el anuncio llegado después de la
prohibición definitiva en este país
africano en medio de las tensiones entre
francia y la junta militar y la red de
las tropas francesas del territorio
maliense reporteros sin fronteras
aseguró que creara sitios espejo de
nuestras cadenas que son copias más o
menos exactas de los sitios web que las
autoridades locales han bloqueado en
mali
los reporteros sin fronteras puso en
marcha una iniciativa llamada libertad
colateral en 2015 y significa que cada
vez que hay censura en algunos países
complicados cada vez que las autoridades
bloquean los medios libres siempre hay
medios técnicos para desbloquear los
para esto hay una alianza en el que
reporteros sin fronteras con ingenieros
técnicos informáticos que están por
todos lados en varios países crea sitios
de espejo que son copia más o menos
exactas de los sitios web que las
autoridades locales han bloqueado
[Música]
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]